mission impossible forme des experts
très déterminé
les spécialistes sans égal à 100 si tu
as tout contre mesures
mais cette agence provoque le chaos
l'heure est venue de dissoudre mission
impossible est en fait très attention
est ce que vous allez dire
où est elle
aux dernières nouvelles il traque le
syndicat
la cia n'a jamais su le moindre
renseignement sur le syndicat vous
voulez la réponse polie ou la vérité
on n'a jamais été présentée je me trompe
suivez-moi
l'état nous et tu le syndicat est bien
réelle une nation dissidente entraînés à
faire ce que nous faisons une anti
mission impossible
ils feront tout pour nous avoir de bruit
ça pourrait bien être notre dernière
mission alors marquant le courant et
c'est quoi le plan
vous voulez en finir avec le syndicat
c'est impossible
ça
tu es sûr que tu peux lui faire
confiance
la situation extrême
mesures extrêmes
l'habitat sain turquie maintenant que tu
le demandes
salut les mecs j'ai raté un truc
au final
tu ouvres la porte rapport ouais
j'essaye
france et forêts